The Origin of the Hokey Pokey
Like many innocuous songs and dances that
you’d assume have fairly benign origins,
the Hokey Pokey is believed by some to have
fairly sinister beginnings.
There are those who insist the song originated
with Scottish Puritans in the UK as an anti-Catholic
taunt.
The words “hokey cokey,” which is how
the song is sung in the UK, is supposedly
derived from the magician’s incantation
“hocus pocus.”
Hocus Pocus popped up in the 17th century
as a part of the conjuration phrase: “Hocus
pocus, tontus talontus, vade celeriter jubeo.”
It’s thought by some that this derived from
the phrase spoken at Catholic Mass: hoc est
enim corpus meum,” or “for this is my
body.”
Thus, this “hokey cokey” origin theory
is that it was supposed to be a jab at the
Catholic doctrine of transubstantiation, the
belief that the bread and wine turn into the
body and blood of Christ during the Mass.
As recently as 2008, a few Catholic Church
officials have considered the “Hokey Pokey”
as an example of “faith hate,” but it
doesn’t seem most took these allegations
all that seriously and there isn’t much
in the way of documented evidence to back
up the “Catholic hate” origin theory.
So what do we actually know about the song?
In 1857, two sisters from Canterbury, England
who were visiting Bridgewater, NH, brought
a little English/Scottish ditty with accompanying
gestures across the pond.
The song is thought to be based on the Scottish
“Hinkum-Booby.”
(“Booby” here referring to the “stupid”
definition, rather than the more modern alternative
definition you might think of when shaking
things about.)
The song went a little something like this:
I put my right hand in,
I put my right hand out,
In out, in out.
shake it all about.
It then continued with other body parts being
put in and out and shaken all about.
Fast-forward to 1940 during the Blitz in London,
a Canadian officer suggested writing an action
party song to English bandleader Al Tabor.
The song’s title, “The Hokey Pokey,”
was supposedly in homage to an ice cream vendor
from Tabor’s childhood, who would call out
“Hokey pokey penny a lump.
Have a lick make you jump.”
In this case, “hokey pokey” was supposedly
a slang at the time for ice cream and the
ice cream seller was called the “hokey pokey
man”.
Presumably borrowing from the aforementioned
English ditty, Tabor put it together with
“hokey pokey” and the song was almost,
but not quite, complete; after all, it’s
called “Hokey Cokey” in the UK.
Tabor claimed he changed the name to “The
Hokey Cokey” at the urging of the same Canadian
officer, who informed him “cokey” was
Canadian slang for “crazy.”
In 1942, the sheet music for “The Hokey
Cokey” was finally published.
Tabor, after a bit of a legal battle, eventually
signed over all rights to the song to famed
Irish songwriter and publisher Jimmy Kennedy
as part of the settlement the two reached
over a lawsuit concerning the song.
It should also be noted here that Kennedy’s
son claimed that Jimmy Kennedy, not Al Tabor,
was the primary author of the lyrics and it
was Jimmy that made the decision to go with
“cokey”.
Across the pond, supposedly independent of
Tabor’s or Kennedy’s work, in 1944, two
musicians from Scranton PA named Robert Degan
and Joe Brier made a record of a song called
“The Hokey Pokey Dance.”
This song was recorded for the entertainment
of the summer crowds at Poconos resorts.
The tune proved to be a regional favorite
throughout the 1940s, but it’s still not
the version that we shake it all about to
today.
In 1949, Charles Mack, Taft Baker and Larry
Laprise, “The Ram Trio,” made their own
version of the song , which is closer to the
version we all know and love today.
The Ram Trio also supposedly independently
developed the song, but in reality probably
learned it from vacationers who’d heard
it at the Poconos resorts.
The song was penned for the amusement of skiers
at the Sun Valley Resort in Idaho.
It proved to be a big hit, so Laprise decided
to record it.
The problem with making such a record and
playing it on the airwaves is that Degan and
Brier got wind of it and sued Laprise for
ripping off their “Hokey Pokey Dance.”
Laprise’s lawyers must have been top-notch,
because even though his version of the song
was released after Degan and Brier’s, Laprise
walked away with the rights to the “Hokey
Pokey Dance.”
Interestingly enough, despite the legal battles
over the song, between Tabor and Kennedy in
the UK and Laprise and Degan/Brier in the
US, going on around the same time, the two
pairs never sought to sue their counterparts
across the pond.
In the end, the ultimate origin of what it’s
all about seems to have been lost to history.
If you choose to believe Al Tabor’s anecdote,
though, at least the recent derivation of
it is about
ice cream.